what are you guys doing
good how are you doing excellent it's
very easy to talk about a good movie
yay uh is it kinda i wanna start with
one of the things that i think is really
interesting is that when something like
this premieres on netflix
you don't have to worry about the
opening weekend box office
you know you're not like staring at it
being like please make some money
because it's just going around the world
and you know what i mean is that sort of
like nice
to know that you don't have to worry
about that box office oh it's
fantastic but there is data right like
it's not like this business isn't data
driven and they don't collect the
numbers they're still tracking eyeballs
um i think what's so exciting though is
i think about a film like american sun
right like when we premiered american
sun that's a film that if we had gone
the box office route it would have been
in two cities in the united states
tiny art house theaters um and we would
have had a
tiny impact based on what we were able
to do with netflix because we over
performed all over the south
over performed in europe um we could see
how many people all over the world
identified with this black family and i
think it's gonna be a
very similar experience like times a
thousand
with the prom because of this incredible
cast and because it's
fun and it's really a party and you know
we're gonna get to see
through the data um depending on how
much of it ryan shares with us because
i'm not a producer on this one
but we're going to get to see how people
all over the world including in
countries where it's still illegal to be
a member of the lgbtq community
how people are engaging with this
material material and embracing it and
celebrating with us
oh i'm just going to say that that's one
of the things i love about netflix is
that
there are so many people that don't have
access to this material
that will be able to see it but and this
brings me this brings me to ryan murphy
one of the things i love about him is
his uh push for
inclusion and diversity both in front of
and behind the camera
on everything he does for both of you
can you sort of talk about
getting to be and work with a filmmaker
like this who is so
pushing the boundary i can't say enough
about ryan murphy i just
i think he's an incredible taste maker
and i'm
so proud to be a part of his universe
now
um i i was so enamored
with with him in my audition process
because he just sat down and asked me a
bunch of questions
and asked me about my lived experience
as as a young queer
woman of color and he really wanted to
use that
um to push the story forward and to
allow alyssa and mrs green to
develop in the into the characters that
you see in our film
um and i'm really grateful that he gave
us the space to talk about that because
there are a lot of conversations to be
had
around in my opinion particularly young
girls of color who identify as lgbtq
because our stories are not told nearly
as often
as the stories of young white males who
identify as
as gay or quite frankly young black
males who identify as gay
so this was a golden opportunity i'm
very grateful that ryan didn't shy away
from it
do you want to add anything i care no
ariana said it all perfectly
i love the song love thy neighbor
because it points out the hypocrisy in
the bible
um i'm sure you guys each have a
favorite song um
in this or maybe you don't i'm not sure
do you have a favorite
you know i've two i love um wear your
crown that rolls in the credits
because i think everybody should be
wearing their crown all the time
um but i also really love unruly heart
that
that you see emma played by joe and
joellen pellman
um saying cause it's just it's our
anthem it really is it's the anthem of
all the unruly hearts
um and you know it's just
sunshine and she sings it so beautifully
and
it's a glorious moment for our community
it's great um
i love it's not about me i mean just
watching meryl do that
live has been getting to see her do it
again and again
and again and there is no stunt double
doing that dancing like those are her
fan kicks that's her belt
like that is her it is really her
because i was in the room
people like and she had already recorded
it but she was still
doing it for real well wow full out wow
i just was so blown away and i love it
it just embodies that whole character
that whole diva
thing i just i love that song i think
it's so funny
and um and she's so perfect in that
moment yeah she's kind of good in that
she's okay yeah for once in her career
she's done exactly
never done anything else um i listen i
love the finale and i think
that people watching it at home are
gonna just it's gonna bring
a lot of people gonna be very happy and
i'm curious it's such a huge number
with so many people what the f was it
like
trying to put that thing on film can you
both share like some backstory
i mean it was a task
days and days in the making yeah it was
it was an all state and there are a
million extras
and but it was a beautiful thing because
you know all of our extras
identify as lgbtq somewhere on the
spectrum
um so to have so many of us in the room
to
to be a part of this huge celebration
the energy was palpable
um you know i really credit ryan and the
team and
um and and casey nicholaw and everyone
our choreographer for trying to keep it
organized because wow what a challenge
but i think the product we have at the
end of
the film it speaks for itself because
i'm bopping and crying as i'm watching
it just as
me now yeah yeah i mean i think i really
do
god bless ryan for i mean when we all
got together
so much laughter so much goofiness we
loved working with each other so much it
was like herding cats like i don't know
how they got us to do anything
thank god actually for the background
artists like all those dancers because
they were so much more disciplined than
we were and um and their work ethic was
so
inspiring because they had so much more
of the heavy lifting to do in terms of
really conveying that celebration you
know they
dance and dance and dance and dance and
then they part ways and we do a little
shimmy but they are like dancing dancing
dancing
um so it was really it just was so much
fun and i look at it
now in a covered world and you're like
when are we ever going to see that again
you know hundreds and hundreds of people
in a room together
singing and sweating and dancing and
crying like just
all kinds of bodily fluids and germ
exposure but we were like in it it was
it was right before the world shut down
and
you know i when i think back on like
when we the first time that ariana and i
did that scene where i
where i say that i love you and you know
we have that reconciliation
because it was a room full of background
actors who were all
lgbtq young people they burst out into
applause because they were they felt
like it was their own mother
telling them the thing that they needed
to hear or maybe that they were lucky
enough to hear
and it was so moving for us and
i went around and hugged 50 of those
young people like i look at the world we
live in now where i i
won't even you know i won't hug my
cousin i won't you know you're
we're so boundried now and i just think
what a precious
experience that we got to share that
with each other
on that note i gotta go both of you did
such a tremendous job
good luck with the rest of the speed
dating thank you